whose idea was spice up your life nah we
have a wonderful creative team that puts
together wonderful ideas for us
hence my pineapple boobs hence the
ruffles and spice of your life but I
mean come on it's pretty clever you got
to give it to him spice up your life and
we tried what's the reaction to the
first dance I was really happy if you
saw where I started what this woman has
done to get me to today it's nothing
short of a miracle
this whole thing was about getting out
of my comfort zone I don't think I'm in
my comfort universe this is this is
payback everybody who ever wanted me to
have to do something crazy they got it
tonight you said a little bit in your
package going in to this that you had to
make up your own decision about Sean and
that obviously you know the Twitter blew
up when you were becoming coming on
Dancing with the Stars so how have you
dealt with you know that sort of
feedback and maybe a little bit of
harshness it's interesting normally and
normally before the premiere people know
the partnerships they had no idea I was
dancing with Sean until maybe 30 minutes
ago so it is going to be natural to see
tons of people having comments about
what we're doing but what I love about
this show is that so many different
people come together and enjoy what we
do and have fun and that's what I want
to do this entire season we're already
having fun and we're gonna continue to
do that taking the shirt home tonight
I've got to be careful because I think
if it gets hot it'll catch on fire so I
may have to wrap it in something
[Music]